I believe that most human beings are
only living at about 40% of their
capability I was able to find strength
in every molecule of this earth I'm able
to be in a room with nothing with no
motivation no inspiration nothing to
find it but what I did as a young kid is
observed everybody wanna soar get a
mentor what's up belief nation it's Evan
I believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn
from one of the best David Goggins and
some of his best motivation for working
hard mentor me David also if you want to
know what David Goggins has to say about
building confidence and excellence stuck
in my 254 series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence the links to join are in the
description below you will never learn
from people if we always tap-dance
around the truth everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get in charge of your brain I
believe that most human beings are only
living at about 40 percent of their
capability so the mind has a governor
like a car if you're driving a car and
the car has a governor on it the car may
say hundred thirty miles an hour but the
governor set for ninety one once that
governor sets in you get the ninety one
that car starts doing this the car wants
to go the crowd wants to go but
definitely factory said uh we're not
going past ninety one we have a factory
a nice governor in our brain and it's a
survival mechanism it protects us from
pain and suffering the second we feel
that our mind says no no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable and
there's some about the mind the mind has
the tactical advantage over you at all
times at all times of your life the mind
has a tactical advantage over you why is
that it knows that you're afraid of it
knows your insecurities it knows your
deep dark lies and it starts to push you
away from that it pushes you in a
direction that is comfortable the mind
controls everything so what I realized
was that when I was growing up and I was
300 pounds and I got all fat and I got
all insecure I realized that my mind
kept taking me in this direction when
things got uncomfortable for me when I
was facing my insecurities I was facing
my fears my mind said oh no we had the
tactical advantage we just get you
separate you from this feeling this
feeling of your life's all about
feelings we want the happy feeling we
don't want that feeling of this sucks
why am I here and you don't have any
choice oh you can't answer those
questions so you leave I started
realizing that if in that moment you can
answer those tough questions and you are
now in charge of your brain versus your
brain ruling you that's where all that
stuff comes from so the 40% rule is all
of that you get to 40% your brain says
we're done let's roll man this is trying
to get painful this is uncomfortable
so you sit down you have to figure out
ways and everybody's different that's
how the book kind of talks about like we
all have these things about you know
five steps to this and four steps to
this it's it's a lot more than that
that's all [ __ ] it's it's a practice
that you have to it's a habit so if you
know that forty percent I'm still you
know I'm feeling pain at 40 percent
feeling pain that's where the 40 percent
rule kicks in now it starts okay I'm
feeling pain my mind saying all this to
me it's saying get out of here run flee
the fight-or-flight kicks in okay we're
done we're not good enough it starts
telling you all these things you start
to believe it because the mind controls
all this is the time we have to gain
control back of your mind
it's okay let me see if I can go 45
percent and once you start giving
yourself more and more hope instead of
realizing okay the mind starts to be
okay what are you doing we're supposed
to be going right and you're going left
you start then controlling your mind
start finding more in you know in
yourself and it goes from 40% to a lot
further than that but that's the start
of it though get to get to the spot
where your mind is saying stop wherever
that is yeah get there first and then
that's when that starts to work for you
you got to control yourself in that
moment rule number 2 find your inner
strength well there's something that I
invented a long time ago and when you
have nothing to draw from I was able to
find strength in every molecule of this
earth I'm able to be in a room with
nothing with no motivation no
inspiration nothing and find it so what
I did in those situation was I invent
this thing called taking souls when
everybody's all up and you're exhausted
and you're weak and you're tired and
you're looking around and everybody
looks as bad as you or even worse I'm
like you know what I want to now make a
statement it's the perfect time to make
a statement to make a statement to let
you know where your life ends and mine
begins and so the statement there is I
muster up every bit of strength from
their looks on their faces and how they
feel and how I'm gonna now
from my childhood where I came from
how's the bottom of the barrel I'm now
amongst all these uncommon people I'm
now going to now make you feel like
you're common so I used their their
sadness their weakness their parts of
their life oh god this sucks I'm like
all poopy pants too messed up
I used that for my strength and I have
this moment of like let's say we're in
the sand we running or whatever I will
do a surge I will do something everybody
had a is he doing this and from that
that look on their face that feeling of
God man this guy must be something
something special
it didn't services me further and
further and faster and harder for a long
time so it's energies everywhere
but the thing is it's so loud that that
that voice in your head of pain and
suffering and discomfort and I don't
want to do this is so loud that you're
unable to really calm it down it's okay
there's something here it's a patient
calm that you have to bring your
substitute I know I have something here
but that voice is so powerful that it's
want you just to let's leave right we're
done we're done it spazzes you out and
you want to go versus saying let's take
a second hang on
before we [ __ ] out hang on and in
that moment you can think clearly and
find that strength out therefore you
will number three ask yourself what if I
would like to know when you're in that
moment failing and you have to keep
going what do you say to yourself what
if a lot of times I'll be in a tours at
Mile Run or something like that and I'm
all jacked up body's broken mines broken
spirits broken I started to say what if
I can pull this off when I first walked
into the Navy SEAL recruiters office he
looked at me and said only been 35
african-americans and seventy years make
it through you know I said to myself
what if I can be the 36 it's the what if
I can pull off a miracle
what if I can become someone that no one
thinks I can be and just that just means
talking about that I have the hair going
up on my arms because it makes me just
like what if I can be that guy that
people who call [ __ ] and this and that
and now I'm speaking at tom ferry event
what is that's it
rule number four keep getting up growing
up being the kid I was I found strength
in different movies yeah so I come home
in one movie I found a lot of strength
as funny as it may seem but I visualized
this scene I do it today during the pull
up record if 4030 pull-ups in the last
time I did actually got it to be three
times I played one song for 17 hours
pretty much it's from this movie Rocky
one round 14 mm-hmm I related to the
person in the movie mm-hmm but just the
one scene when Apollo's beaten Iraqi he
falls in the corner and everybody in
rocky and Apollo turns around arms up
happy I got this guy he turns around not
knowing that Rocky is trying to get up
up off the canvas
Mickey st. Mickey's his trainer saying
stay down or everybody saying you did
good you did good you had 14 rounds with
the champ rocky didn't hear he got up
and was Dick's in my mind today seen it
right now when he got up a power starts
to turn around to see the aftermath and
with the penis destroyed and he did not
expect to see what he saw right and when
I see the whole movie I see a power
crease face yeah fear of crept in yes it
I said to myself as a young kid I want
to be that mm-hmm I don't need to win I
don't need trophies I need people like
me I just want what he has
yeah a fictional character whatever the
hell was I want that and I visualized
that and I want to become the guy who
can get off the canvas and look at
somebody who beat the fish out of him
life was about life right now
in life even life itself pushed her head
down towards Ava gosh yeah this is not
going to stop so that mentality became
what I wanted nice and that's how it
started with that visualization of the
canvas mm-hmm and all I got to do is
just keep getting up and rule number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is don't make excuses what
was the greatest lesson your mom taught
you growing up honestly the greatest
lesson she had taught me is a lesson
that she did she doesn't know how much
she taught me because she wasn't much in
the teaching mode my dad took her soul
but what I did as a young kid is I
observed
everybody I wasn't really smart in the
books
yeah I was real smart when it came to
life yeah and I was able to sit back and
watch her mistakes I was able to see how
she struggled through life and how I
don't want to struggle through life and
I was able to see she never picked me up
the biggest thing she did for me and
this is honest-to-god truth and she
doesn't know she did it without busting
my ass but I would fail you know when I
was at the bottom of the sewer she never
picked me up she never gave me that
cookie and said hey son you know it's
gonna be okay no she didn't have time
for that and sometimes she gets upset
when I talk about my past because it
paints her out to be not the best mom if
I had any kind of mom in that kind of
environment I would have never made it
mmm because she forced me for ever
reason she forced me did you better
figure this out or are you gonna be a
statistic mom and this is something she
didn't sit down and tell me I realized
this this is the world that is in front
of me and what most people do is they
see this world and they look at it as an
excuse to get out of it yeah I started
looking at it as this is the ultimate
training ground for the rest of my life
mm-hmm I have all these valuable lessons
because if you look out in the world
right now today it's not a nice place
I'm very prepared for it yeah you are
I'm prepared for it I'm prepared for all
the failure coming my way I'm prepared
for everything my way and that's the
biggest lesson that she taught me by not
teaching me mmm by never saying it's
gonna be okay I'm a fact she told me
exact opposite life sucks
now I've got a special bonus clip from
David Goggins on how to commit fully
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what excuse are you
making that you need to let go of number
two what's your answer to what if and
number three what do you need to get up
from
talk about taking Souls this morning
this person I usually train alone first
abundant Romani
I said 5:15 this morning comes this
doors coming in this way and the person
calls and said hey why don't we do it
tomorrow
taking souls is when I told them I'm
gonna run 15 today and I run through
again tomorrow
that's what taking solace is about don't
worry about the elements and what's
going on you gotta get out there and get
it and that's taking souls and obviously
he wasn't the only one that fell about
taking the day off because the storm is
coming in right now and there's not a
soul I hear but me
if you want more David Goggin check of
the top 10 rules video made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I'm not the smartest
kid in the world okay it says somebody
saying oh no you're smart no no I don't
say that to yourself I said to myself no
I'm a dumb